[Music]
putting the topic of care delay on a
larger stage and enabling us to spread
the word around the need for
transformation and care systems in
different countries and in different
systems around the world
so it gave us an opportunity or pushing
designer to this building story we're
becoming richer as a society but we are
also becoming more than alive and I
really wanted to do something about it
and not to speak what design would do
that for the user and for us is time to
Train
the speed of design is very very much so
fact that you and I don't have been
sustainable buildings means that they
are currently not mainstream how can we
expect that of course to the word to
live in those those are key drivers
[Music]